thank you
[Music]
welcome back everybody to a wonderful
episode of careful boys today we have
the person you've been asking for for so
long he is back Jason Cheney
why'd you leave us for so long
Where Have You Been thank you guys so
much
thank you guys welcome back thank you
Joe welcome back thank you man it's so
nice it's so nice
t-shirts that say it's so nice that's so
nice wait do you have merch
but then um I don't want to pack them
and do the thing so I just said it's
sold out but I have a bunch
it's not nothing assault but I have a
budget you have a shirt that says that's
so nice this is your catchphrase you
have to have that as a shirt does that
feel right it just feels yeah of course
if yeah I just um it's like a grateful
thing it's like this is a nice thing you
know when did you start saying that so
much you could
um when you say that's I don't know
maybe like four or five years I never
heard anybody say that's so nice the
Pandy kind of I kind of picked up more
that's so nice new in the Pandy did you
get some more gratitude when did you
start saying the pen
racially ambiguous if another panty
happens are you against the Lockheed or
no
are you your lockies are cool I'll have
more lockies
um I I feel like some people if you want
to do the lucky you could be any
but then if you don't want to lock it
you can beat on the outside you could be
the lucky the any or the Audi okay
I'm confused
you could go with any or you could be
the Audi I want to be sometimes any
sometimes out
so you don't want you don't want lucky
at all you're just in and out the whole
time yeah yeah but sometimes I want
other people to be inside and I want to
be out there is there a particular type
of person that you want to be inside
um the handies the blacks
no I'm sorry I don't know why I said
that I apologize so we haven't seen you
that's terrible we haven't seen you in
so long we actually have to do a
catching up with Jason now because we
don't know where you've been yeah where
you've been all over the world
you just got in from Washington uh yeah
last show we did there's so many jk
people that came to Washington
yeah thank you guys thank you guys
yeah I love when you guys do that we
have the best fan you know what's crazy
is that every time the JK people when
they come out they they all have like
the kind of the same Vibe they're all
cool they're all nice is the thing
seriously they have like that's the JK
collabo merch they're all nice
but you could tell the insides they're
they're a little bit crazy but uh but on
the outside they're really nice how can
you tell they're crazy on the inside
um some some of them would dye their
hair and they're like hi I'm like I
don't think that's you know what I mean
I think there's more than
just because they dye their hair no
would that I think it takes a certain
type of personality to be like this is
um this purple and green who I am yeah
I mean it's like a statement yeah yeah
risk you know and then but then yeah you
would never die I did it when I was um a
little younger and uh what was it like a
snow cone yellow blue and red I
but then um
but then I was like that's not me
because I feel like yeah but they're
super I never dyed my hair you never
have I think I should
yeah you might as well live it up what
you got what color would you do it
though
magenta yeah I got you what color is
magenta
it's magenta maybe like a bolder darker
version of the box next to a pink yeah
like this it's a pink purple it's like
Takis what do you think do you think
that would look good on him
um depends what I wear I feel like a
teal I think that'll give you split ends
teal Teal's kind of cool your
pillowcasing to be so [__] though
really it'll die
the color rubs off oh [__] what's a
color that hasn't been used as much
platinum he's black
I think that's a good idea
oh like it's like matte black
flag this is gloss black just so it
doesn't shine
super dry hair the Black is Black you
can find vantablack yeah textured black
yeah that's that's right and then when
you sweat
just black little wig
do I understand this correctly did you
have a kid recently yeah I had a baby
like wow what the [__] yeah I didn't
even know your wife was pregnant she was
Prego how can we never told us was a
surprise yeah I was a surprise well
thank you I'm surprised yeah he
mentioned I got you I got four month
Mark holy [__] your kids four months now
yeah four months how's it like being a
dad I don't know um yeah it's really
easy because you don't do nothing on the
road
I just have it and I'm like but I'm
pro-choice
um but yeah
people act like no you looking for poor
choice no this is a funny thing to say
after being a father
No I um I don't want I want it
[Laughter]
you're convincing yourself yeah I tried
to I tried it every day I do but people
act like people walk around and act like
like
um it's normal to have like humans like
parents don't really talk about the
thing but it's like um it's like a weird
thing you know why is it weird like it's
just a
I'm not I'm not having sex
yeah you're not having sex no but yeah
so you had a baby without having sex
yeah yeah but uh previously yeah
oh cause your wife's too tired or what
what I think it's just uh you're too
tired I I think it's just like the
atmosphere is not sexy atmosphere is not
sexy yeah and then when they go wet and
then your penis get soft a little bit oh
yeah it feels like it's your problem I
think that's the proper response yeah
she didn't have a raging bone or what a
baby
I think the opposite would be a bad
problem yeah I don't know is uh and
sometimes it's
feed the you know feed it and then the
breastfeeding no you don't like you
don't like how that looks no it looks
nice sometimes you're jealous no I don't
get jealous maybe a little bit yeah
maybe a little bit of which though yeah
wow
yeah
yeah connection real feeling cool you
know what the thing is is uh when the
what made me really uncomfortable was
the newer doctors and I respect all the
doctors but when there's there's newer
dogs like they're young like a young
doctor like a young doctor yeah because
oh I see what you mean when he put the
epidural in my wife's spine yeah he he
put it and he was like oh um he said oh
um
I didn't flopped his hand out like that
I'm like what do you mean oh
yeah because because like keep it to
yourself because yeah because that's
because I would say be a professional
because when I was a waiter I was a
professional yeah I know it's not the
same thing but it's like what it is
though it is because if you come to the
restaurant and you're like hey man
where's my food I go well let my friends
didn't get my food where's mine and then
I'll go the kitchen's really backed up
let me go check for you blame it on
someone else yeah yeah you
that I may have put in his order so you
want the doctor to go oh they didn't
make the needle right yeah
and your wife's spine's all weird
[Laughter]
but he didn't tell you anything else
after that did it work though otherwise
your wife was like oh [__] okay cool
thank God is it her no more like that
for a second but then but yeah after it
was good but um yeah everything it was I
I looked at it and I hurt a little bit
and then because of the what are you
talking about the JJ yeah did you look
geez you have to make it so big you have
to I have to too so curious I had to
like it's it's crazy yeah
does your kid have a lot of hair yeah
mine too so you see a [__] emerging
emerging [__] like you see the vagina
lips yeah you just see a [__]
emerging
just start coming out yeah and then like
so Jill's pushing
and then the minute she takes a break
and then it starts going back in and
they're like we're trying to push and
then the uh glad you wore a black shirt
today man
thank God and then and then the uh you
wanna use my shirt and the doctor
um he was trying to help and he was like
this big dude I'm talking about like
each one of his fingers look like this
he's like don't worry I got you and
you're like sticking and [__] like
lube and he would just like go to that
the inside and went away yeah just to
help Bloom it up so it comes out I just
never seen that thing get stretched out
so much in my life some people like rip
most women rip it yeah people cut it
yeah and then cut it
so [__] curious and there's nothing
like Geo can do about it because if I
want to see she's kind of like prevent
me yeah because she's [__] like
lockdown yeah yeah and then oh did you
get to cut that Bella before I cut it
that's pretty cool huh yeah yeah the
doctor comes do you want to do on my
[__] ammo until the doctor goes oh I'm
again do they allow you to cut it with
your own choice
like a ceremonial song
[Laughter]
you put on sharper teeth come on
put it between a hot dog bun I want to
bond with my baby
um no we're at Cedars uh I think it was
the Beverly one oh wow cool okay Cedar
cyanide baby how come they've been doing
some oh ums at Cedars that's what I'm
saying they're the best I thought Kaiser
was going to be yeah
you know they call Kaiser they call them
killer Kaiser really yeah in the
healthcare World they call them that
yeah
no this is just one I hear it because
this is what I heard Don't Kill the
Messenger dude though
but yeah so like fatherhood like what's
it like
did you did you cry the first time you
had your baby
no I I uh I didn't cry
yeah I cried for when my grandfather
died but I didn't want to cry but it
just came out
um yeah so what happened when you got
the baby I was like really stressed out
um because I just want I I think too
much and I just don't want my wife and
my the baby to die I was like why did
you say it like that role are you
training for I don't know what it is I
don't want to make it sad what didn't
you think either of them were gonna what
makes you think either we're gonna die I
don't know because sometimes you know
like the heartbeat on the monitor is
like PPP and then
because there's a range and sometimes
it's like over or under yeah and the
baby was like overall and I don't know
medical things and I was like over how
long is it gonna die was your baby going
oh
[__] yeah is it five minutes okay is ten
minutes is is five hours okay I don't
know oh yeah and no one tells you
because the guy's too busy going oh um
oh um yeah so many times you can't trust
his word after this and the stethoscope
listen listen and he goes I'm like did
you hear the [__] though yeah but he's
still here but yeah your baby's first
words are oh um
that would be really funny yeah did you
did you guys do the whole golden hour
thing was it golden now take your shirt
off and hug the baby belly to belly so
that golden hour is like the mom like
you want to get the mom oh you want to
get the baby on the mom skin the skin
contact ASAP yeah they did that so then
you can have
um like bonding yeah and it's when the
doctor did that I was like man [__] that
I took my shirt off because I climbed I
climbed oh you did it too long and the
doctor was laughing I'm like this ain't
funny [__]
this is real oh that's not a standard
for the guy to do nah it's usually the
dude just like over there I'm like yeah
[__] I'm trying to find Tyga so much
like you maybe
yeah I just took my shirt off right
there and I think the doctor was like I
guess his first time for anything
that sounds like a good doctor yeah were
you holding the baby immediately what
else you hold the baby and I was where
did you go okay you already had the baby
hold the whole nine months is my turn
yeah you didn't do that no I was like
scared I was like you hold it because I
don't but I hold it you had her for so
long
it does come more natural to women I
went to moms like when it comes out they
just like know the perfect place
placement like dad's day one is like I
guess I'm supposed to I guess I'm
supposed to love you but you know
there's I can't put you here
I got books
[Music]
I think dads get better at being dads
because there are more around it but
moms man it was like
yeah it goes like this they just forget
how to do it what did you decide on a
name Eris really
[Laughter]
but I left like uh two days after I just
did the road yeah
I was like pro-choice
or something so you just have to leave
yeah but we we did a uh induce so then
um like we scheduled it so that I could
be there because I didn't want to miss
out on demonics yeah oh yeah so I was
doing it and do the road
um but yeah I don't know but you get to
did you always get to see your kid like
all the time well in the beginning all
the time
for the first month yeah okay yeah every
day yeah this may have bonded
immediately yeah and we have that luxury
because they run our own [__] so like we
knew what was going on so we kind of
like scheduled things oh we're like okay
I'm gonna like uh I still worked but
then I was able to like go home at a
certain time or whatever so I could see
the kid as much as possible that's
really nice yeah yeah but uh some dads
are just better than other dads you know
some dogs
yeah I didn't like I didn't induce
anything and try to leave yeah
hahaha
you stay there that's interesting yeah
also worried about that how long did you
get to hang out with your baby
but I hang out a couple days and then he
left for a month
I just got back
shout out to all the Jacob no
keeping me honorable
[Laughter]
uh yeah I came back and stuff
um we left around the road were you like
more worried or more you know that's the
thing like sometimes
um like I I wanna it's hard to I have to
shut off my emotions I think like when
I'm on the road I don't even want to see
you or I think it's like being in prison
like sometimes you just don't want to
see them because you're like I just
forget about you because or or if you
keep thinking about it it's like really
hard yeah oh I know what you mean yeah
yeah you'd rather just be present I'm on
the road I'm here to do a show I'll do
that versus like my brain over there
then it constantly constantly haunts you
because you have there's nothing you can
do because you're [__] another state
it's good to learn how to say that
differently yeah
yeah yeah
it sounded so harsh at first yeah
I think a kid is like a prison
did you get to FaceTime at all yeah
FaceTime and I look but you're like I
gotta go I don't want to be able
[Laughter]
yeah but it's nice though send send like
all the family oh I didn't know Koreans
have like the 100 day things that look
baby yeah because they what's that like
uh when they live to a hundred days they
do like a rice cake thing oh cool it's a
little ceremony yeah I think before
um it's hard for babies to live to 100
days because before that they die sorry
sorry
shout out to all the ones that didn't
I don't know why I said that about that
but but she made it so that's good
that's cool they put like like money and
like like random things to see what to
see what the baby grabs and then like
you know that game they play oh like the
to see if the baby's gonna be a doctor
Oh I thought that was to see if it was a
Reincarnation of the Emperor or
something
a lot of babies will wear like the gold
things what is that the bracelet yeah I
don't know what that is Chinese I don't
know I thought that's the thing that
tells you what you're allergic to yeah
or what your mood is right
is it that thing that helps you balance
look see where's my arm down here
just all of those did you guys trust
that though like the the balance thing
no but a janitor at my old job he's he
lived by it he was like his 80 year old
grandpa and he goes look and he has like
the thing he does the test he goes oh
that's so strong he goes you put it on
you put it on and you put it on my thing
goes oh my God I can't even get it there
you got the sales pitch I trusted at
first babies could benefit from this
yeah you should get one for your baby
yeah
um just cover your baby in this Power
Band
just never fall it starts walking
[Laughter]
so have you thought about getting your
baby a agent a commercial agent no way
baby shoots I would never wanted her to
do that what if somebody was like hey
you can make some monies
how much how much we'll just drink water
[Laughter]
uh no I want her to have like a normal
life and then later if she wants to do
it yeah maybe not maybe not a comedian
but uh yeah but because I feel like the
baby
um I don't want to do it I don't want to
put because this is like a weird way for
humans in the beginning I feel like it
would be nice to have community and play
with other kids and um do slides and
stuff what if you're what if your baby
went or what if your daughter when she's
like eight is like Dad I want to open
for you
yeah you uh opened us there
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign